i hug people people come up to me and
hug me all the time
i don't mind shaking hands i'll fist
bump you i'll hug you i don't like the
excessive hug you know some people they
hold on a little too long don't like
that kind of hug but just the hey how
you doing hug that's just fine these
people they have allowed fear to become
the driving factor in their life fear
and control is what drives them it
should not drive you these are paranoid
crazy people at this point and heck of a
segway there too speaking of paranoid
crazy people here's fouchy
a day
after the ridiculous state of the union
where that 80 year old man was hugging
and kissing and sniffing hair and
everything else here's fauci saying it's
still too risky to unmask kids now we
could get lucky because the trajectory
right now is going way down
and it very well may be
that if you take masks off the kids in
the next week or so it's going to keep
going down but you've really got to be
careful you know you don't want to say
it's an absolutely wrong decision
it's understandable
why people want to take masks off the
kids
but right now given the level of
activity that we have
it is risky
yeah just shut up man like enough enough
and don't worry guys you know i always
tell you that i try to do the positive
coveted stories i'm going to get to some
more desantis stuff in just a second
but i think it's i had to show you this
stuff because it's important to see how
the system seemingly was ready to move
on two days ago so it gives you this
like odd glimmer of hope and then two
days later fauci no we're gonna still
put the kids and again he never does the
numbers right it's never about the
numbers when it gets to the lowest point
that it's going to get and we'd see the
trend going down then we could do this
or that or the other thing
please tell me this fouchy lord fauci
please tell me who is more at risk that
80 year old man with a bunch of other
geriatric people who were all on top of
each other applauding and clapping and
and all of that stuff versus a bunch of
young
five-year-olds in a classroom with a
teacher who's obviously vaxxed
tell me but you can't tell me because
this is all complete
nonsense and you know it uh speaking of
biden uh the daily wire had this little
funny clip it's only about 30 seconds
just showing how what biden said
during the state of the union about how
we have to heal and nobody's our enemy
and everything else that is just
complete [ __ ] just as per what he
said only a few weeks before take a look
there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated so stop looking at coven as
a partisan dividing line
see it for what it is
a god-awful disease
let's stop sending each seeing each
other as enemies
and start seeing each other for who we
are
fellow americans
why are you the way that you are
i mean the most generous version of that
that you could give to biden is that he
just don't know doesn't know what he's
saying right that he just they put
something in front of him and he reads
and he just has no idea what he's saying
but look that was january of 2022 right
so it's you know five weeks ago he's
saying it's still a pandemic of the
unvaccinated and there's no reason for
anyone to be unvaccinated and the
implication is like you're going to pay
somehow we're going to get you if you're
unvaccinated well joe i'm unvaccinated
what are you going to do to me what do
you i mean really are we at the point
you're going to are you going to close
down my bank are you going to arrest me
like what are you going to do i made the
choices that were right for me and i got
coveted and i have natural immunity by
the way it's not just me it's that scary
joe rogan guy got covered has natural
immunity there's plenty of other people
that made choices for themselves but
think about how just divisive he was
five weeks ago pandemic of the
unvaccinated complete lie we know that
vaccinated people get coveted transmit
covet et cetera et cetera um
and then what he says at the state of
the union the entire state of the union
was one
lie
after another just one endless lie after
another